raoul nar hwanhee okay Raoul says this
putting co2 back into the earth in
pressurized condition after absorption
is this feasible what we talked about
carbon capture your car they call it X
carbon capture exactly is it feasible
yeah so I it turns out from what I have
read if you want to remove carbon from
the air that we have put in the energy
requirement to do that you're going to
ask we're gonna get the energy to that
make that right and if you're doing it
you know you're gonna burn oil to
capture the carbon right so if you're
doing it with solar power and or
something that does not have a carbon
footprint that you could have used that
for your energy in the first place
that's right why right so so these are
some of the challenges the you know that
will confront us as we move forward I'm
going to be great if we can have some
way to just dump the stuff back into the
back into the ground the limestone is
sequestered carbon basically right and
so but then involve life forming it so
if you could do that yeah burn away you
know burn baby burn and bury it but
various we're not there yet we're not
that would no you don't have that much
power over geoengineering to turn that
into a thing so really the the better
solution is switching then trying to
deal with continuing to burn and burn
it's like oh what's the solution to acid
rain let's all Kari let's talk later
Absalom for umbrellas right let's all
coat everything in an ethical welcome
layer of some type of yeah this depends
on how you're thinking about solving a
problem right that's all okay gotcha all
right if you like this please remember
everything that we do can be found
commercial free plus exclusive original
content all on Startalk all-access calm